We've already seen several
videos where we, one, learned
what the Pythagorean theorem is
and how it can be applied
to find the sides of right
triangles, and even to find
the distances between points
on the Cartesian plane, so
this is the Pythagorean
theorem.
And just as a bit of review, it
tells us that if I have a
right triangle, and if c is the
side opposite the right
angle, right?
That's my right angle.
c is that side.
It's the longest side.
We call that the hypotenuse.
Then the square of the other
sides, the sum of the squares
of the other sides, will
be equal to c squared.
So if this side is a and this
side is b, the Pythagorean
theorem tells us that a squared
plus b squared is
going to be equal
to c squared.
And we did several problems
where we used this to solve
different triangles.
But what I want to show you
in this video is really a
visual-- you can view it as
a visual proof of the
Pythagorean theorem to see why
this actually makes sense.
And to understand that, I'm
going to draw a little bit of
a diagram here.
So let me draw a little
right triangle here.
So let's say that that
is my right triangle.
And let's say that this
is a, this is b,
that is my right angle.
Then that right there, this
right here, that length right
there is c.
Now, what I'm going to do is
draw this exact same triangle,
but I'm going to rotate
it a little bit.
You're going to see what
I'm talking about.
This right here is the exact
same triangle that I just
drew, except I rotated it.
So this is a, this is b,
and now this is c.
This is the exact-- you could
do this, you know.
You could take a ruler out
and actually do it.
Pick an a, b, and c, and you
can actually rotate this
triangle around to the
right like this.
You could just rotate it like
that, and you would get this
triangle, just like that.
Now, I'm going to
rotate it again.
And I'm just going to imagine
copy and pasting it.
And then I'll get this triangle,
just like that.
And once again, this is a,
this is b, and this is c.
These triangles are all the
exact same triangle, the exact
same measure.
Now let me rotate this again,
and I'll get this triangle.
I will get this triangle
right here.
And once again, this is a.
This length right here is a.
This length right here is b.
And this is the hypotenuse of
this right angle, this is c.
Now what do we have here?
We have all of these right
angles, and inside, I have
this other square that
is inscribed
into this right angle.
And I can prove to you, if you
like, that these are also
right angles.
And you know, why don't
I just show it to you.
You may or may not already be
familiar that the angles in a
triangle add up to 180.
So if you call this angle x, you
call this angle y, we know
that x plus y plus 90 degrees
have to be equal to 180.
So x plus y plus 90 have
to be equal to 180.
Or you could say that if you
subtract 90 from both sides of
this equation, x plus y are
going to be equal to 90.
I just subtracted 90
from both sides.
This disappears.
180 minus 90 is 90.
And this x and y, they're
all over.
If this angle is x right here,
so is this angle because this
is the exact same triangle.
So is this angle.
If this angle is y, so is that
angle, so is that angle, and
so is that angle.
Now, you may or may not already
know that if you have
three angles that form a line--
so let me draw it.
If you have three angles that
form a line like this, so
let's say we have angle a,
angle b-- let me draw b a
little bit different-- and angle
c, just like that, and
together they kind of form you
could imagine a semi-circle or
they go from one line all the
way back, that a, b plus c are
going to be equal to 180.
a plus b plus c is going to
be equal to 180 degrees.
They complete a 180-degree
arc.
Now, if you look at, let's say,
this point right here on
our diagram, you can see that
angle x plus this angle right
here, which I'll call angle z, x
plus z plus y is going to be
equal to 180 degrees.
They form a line.
So x plus z plus y, or maybe I
should write it as x plus y
plus z is equal to 180.
Now, we already know x plus y
is equal to 90, so this is
equal to 90.
So 90 plus z is equal to 180.
z minus-- well, both sides
of this equation minus 90
degrees, you get 180 minus 90.
I just subtract 90 from
both sides, so z
is equal to 90 degrees.
So these are all 90-degree
angles.
Their sides are all the same
length of c, so this is a
square in the middle
of this diagram.
Now, let's think a little
bit about what the area
of the square is.
And there's two ways we
can come up with the
area of that square.
So let me draw something here.
So the first easy way to think
of the area of the square,
well, it's a square.
This length is c, that
length is c.
To figure out the area, I
just multiply one side
by the other side.
It's c times c, or c squared.
So if I want the area of that
right there, it is c
squared, c times c.
Area is equal to c squared.
But how else could we figure
out that area?
Well, we could say that would
be the area of this larger
square, of this whole square
over here minus the area of
these triangles.
That also would give us the area
of that inside square.
So what is the area of this
outside, bigger square?
Well, each of its sides
are a plus b.
And so you take a plus b.
If you want the area, you could
say, a plus b times a
plus b, or a plus b
squared, right?
That's the area of the outer
square, but we still have to
get the area of our
inner square.
Area of small square.
We still have to subtract out
the area of these triangles.
And what are the areas
of these triangles?
Well, we have to subtract out.
The area of each of them is 1/2
times base times height,
or base times height,
ab, 1/2 ab.
That's the area of each
of these triangles.
Now we have 1, 2, 3, 4
So it's 4 times 1/2 ab.
This is another way of getting
the area of this inside
smaller square.
Now let's just do a little bit
of algebra-- we're pretty
familiar with this-- to
essentially simplify the
right-hand side of this
equation right here.
So a plus b times times a plus
b, a times a is a squared,
plus 2 ab, plus b squared.
And then we have minus-- what
do we have right here?
Minus 2ab, right?
4 times 1/2 is 2,
so minus 2 ab.
Well, these cancel out.
2ab minus 2ab, we're just left
with a squared and b squared.
So the area of this inside
circle, which is c squared,
it's also equal to a squared
plus b squared.
And I've just to shown you
a visual proof for the
Pythagorean theorem, because
remember, a and b were the
smaller sides of a right
triangle having c as its
hypotenuse.
And from there, we constructed
this bigger diagram.
Hopefully, you found that fun.